okay so we already looked at
steve scalise turning a question about
marjorie taylor green's outrageous
comments
into an answer about china joe biden and
carbon
let's now go to our second example of
the day
this is republican congresswoman nancy
mace asked on fox news
about the ludicrous things that marjorie
taylor greene has said
remember we've uncovered videos of
marjorie taylor green
talking about jewish space lasers as the
cause for california wildfires
marjorie taylor greene uh being a 911
denier
marjorie taylor green um talking about
political violence as a good thing as
something that that needs to be done on
and on and on republicans are being
asked to comment
nancy mace is a republican congresswoman
from south carolina
some believed not me but some believed
that she was a more moderate rational
voice in the republican party
she went on fox news yesterday she was
asked about marjorie taylor green's
comments and she actually
to her credit she seemed to concede that
marjorie taylor greene
is crazy but she played the both sides
games saying there are crazy people on
both sides
and then gave a number of false
equivalencies so let's take a look but
there are crazies on both sides of the
aisle
we've seen that um you know it's not
just republicans that have our own
issues
democrats have them too we've seen
maxine waters
tell folks to go and threaten and harm
members of the
trump administration right we've seen
crazies on both sides of the aisle
we do have to i think address some of
these issues but you know some of these
things and i'm learning about them today
and this week too were said before she
was elected and
georgia voters still elected her um just
a few years ago we saw democrat another
democrat from georgia
uh cynthia mckinney assault a capitol
hill police officer and nothing was done
after that either so
we've got to look at precedent we've got
to have this conversation we have to
address it and if we do a better job
of holding ourselves accountable we can
also hold the left accountable as well
we we have to have that moral authority
and that means addressing some of these
situations so listen
if you if you need me to find something
positive about that
she does seem to be saying that marjorie
taylor green is crazy
she is drawing false equivalencies to
maxine waters though and
also saying this stuff was said before
marjorie greene
was elected is is not particularly
relevant
this is gaslighting this is what about
ism two-side stuff
and it's a complete farce and at least
she's admitting marjorie taylor green
is crazy but maxine waters never
followed around
an 18 year old kid that was at a school
during a school shooting
accusing that kid of wanting to take her
guns away as marjorie taylor green did
to david hogg maxine waters never said
that there were wildfires started by
i don't know catholic space lasers or
anything like that
and by the way even if these examples
from the other side were equivalent
they're in the past and they have
nothing to do
with nancy mace and republicans now
dealing with marjorie taylor greene
who is in her own party at this point in
time
nancy mace actually has a sort of clever
approach to a lot of these interviews
i've seen other interviews where when
nancy mace is asked what you would think
or questions she really has to answer
she'll sort of fast talk through a bunch
of distortions and lies it's sort of a
gish gallop technique
and very often anchors or interviewers
even you either don't have the
wherewithal
or skill to point it out or just don't
have the time because a lot of these
segments last
you know four minutes it's hard to
refute six lies in four minutes
and nancy mace used very similar talking
points
on cnn over the weekend they are
terrible talking points
but she is getting away with them and as
i said before
i am disgusted that republicans
even with these people aren't just
straight up calling them out and saying
there's no room for this insanity in the
republican party obviously it's
disappointing they're not doing that
i'm not surprised that they're not doing
it but there is a political calculation
happening here
where to some degree i think they
believe the further they get from
january 6th the further they get from
trump being
in office the more they can kind of just
shut their mouths about these people
and claim that they're about legislation
and they're about stopping socialism and
government takeovers of health care and
uh reducing the deficit all that stuff
that they pretend to care about
and just sort of not comment on people
like marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
madison cawthorne and others
so ultimately i believe that the test as
to whether these
radical new members of congress will
become a significant part of the
republican party
will be whether they get re-elected in
2022
democrats do have a path to expelling
these folks
from committee assignments but
it would take republicans to really be
able to get them out of the house of
representatives i don't expect it to
happen
we talked on the bonus show yesterday
about how there have only been five
expulsions in the history of the house
three of them were in the 1800s against
members who were straight up supporting
the confederacy
the other two were in the 20th century
was one of them in the 21st
the other two were in the modern
political era and they were
for members of congress who had actually
been convicted of crimes and so
i am not optimistic at all that we are
going to see these folks expelled
of course it says a lot about the
republican party that they're unwilling
to really take a stand against them
but that's not particularly surprising
to me i'd be shocked if it were to you
if you've been paying attention to what
has happened to the republican party
um even casually over the last few years
we will take a quick break much more
coming up
in just moments